ukraine has denied any involvement in a
car bombing near moscow that killed the
daughter of a prominent russian
nationalist daria dugina died in the
blast both she and her father alexander
dugan have publicly supported russia's
war on ukraine russia's foreign ministry
speculated that keith might be behind
the bombing but an adviser to ukraine's
president said his country was not a
terrorist state
they call themselves the national
republican army an unknown group that is
now claiming responsibility for the
killing of dario dugina
in a video statement read by a former
russian lawmaker the group threatened
more attacks on people with connections
to the kremlin but there are doubts that
an improvised movement could have
carried out such a sophisticated attack
investigations over the death of daria
dogina continue the russian
investigative committee says an
explosive planted in the vehicle killed
a 29 year old tv commentator
the power of the explosion was evident
parts of the toyota land cruiser were
strewn across a large area
her father alexander dugin may however
have been the target of the attack
russian state media said dugin was
intending to travel in the vehicle but
changed his mind at the last minute
both dugin and his daughter were on
their way to moscow after they attended
a cultural festival
alexander dugan is one of the staunchest
allies of president vladimir putin and a
far-right philosopher and author
he has been pushing for a revival of the
russian empire
his daughter although less known was
also a prominent member of the ultra
nationalist movement supporting russia's
invasion of ukraine
she called for genocide of ukrainians
she called ukrainians a sub-human race
she called for public uh public uh
killings of ukrainian prisoners of war
et cetera so yes she's a dugan's
daughter but she is first of all a very
active member of uh russian
far-right nationalist neo-nazi
influential scene
russia's federal security service is now
accusing ukraine of being behind the
blast
a spokesperson for ukrainian president
volody mia selenski has denied keith was
involved
now this story is of course being
closely followed in ukraine and for more
let's bring in dws roman gonzalenko who
joins us from kiev a roman this
so-called national republican army
claimed responsibility for this attack
what more can you tell us about this
group
well there is still not much information
about that group because nobody knew of
its existence just a few hours ago and
there is still very little information
as i've just said um well they're
claiming that there is no confirmation
of the existence of this group from
other independent sources
and
we still have that
letter where they say uh they claim
responsibility but it's it's it's very
general they do not explain why her so
we still have some more questions than
answers we don't know do not know why
they um started the activities now and
now
half a year after the russian invasion
in ukraine why dugin or his daughter
well they are known people they are
ultra nationalists they support this war
but they are not number one targets um
and
it is still unclear what exactly is
behind it and this this letter i'm
referring to
it looks a bit strange to me for example
there is a quote from a famous uh east
german television sports show uh mahmet
vivia max bessa in german which is like
make do it with us do it better than us
in a russian translation this is a
popular tv show shown in the soviet
union in the 80s so they nearly quote
that television show in that letter
which is makes it a bit strange i
wouldn't even say funny in some parts so
as i've just said more questions than
answers at this moment
now the fsb has gone on the record in
saying that uh ukrainian special forces
were behind this attack the fsb of
course being
russia's foreign intelligence service is
is that likely
well i wouldn't exclude it but at this
moment at this stage it seems unlikely
to me for several reasons first
it's not a ukrainian special forces
style to kill to kill someone like that
in russia we've seen assassinations
by ukrainian forces claimed by ukraine
on the occupied territories in the east
duke of ukraine or in the south of
ukraine we saw that in the previous
years in the region of donbass
when it was controlled by the
separatists officially but unofficially
by russia of course and
there were killings of military men
mostly or collaborators
in this case it's a woman which is very
unusual and it's a woman which is not
very important i would say
so this speaks against it then we have
some information russia claiming it was
a ukrainian woman
that did this this is very new
information just a few minutes ago it
was published in russia claiming it was
a young ukrainian woman who came with
and then left to estonia we cannot
confirm it we cannot verify it there is
no reaction to that in kiev so far
so roman what do you think how will
putin how will the kremlin react to this
act of intimidation
well there is not much he can do um
russia could just um send more rockets
or bigger rockets to ukrainian cities
city cities and kill more civilians or
military um this is this is the only
option uh this is uh something that
people in in kiev are expecting in in
the coming days because of the special
date 24th of august is the day of
independence in ukraine which also marks
six months since russia started the open
invasion of ukraine so everybody the the
the atmosphere here in the capital is
very tense and everybody is expecting a
possible russian strike but on the other
hand there is also defiance
thank you very much my colleague roman
goncharenko there reporting from keith
thank you roman